I think the president is a coward when  it comes to helping kids who are afraid  of gun violence I think he is cool when  he doesn't deal with helping our  dreamers though of which were very proud  I think he's in denial about the  Constitution about the climate crisis  however that's about the election this  is about the elect taken up in the  election this is about the Constitution  of the United States and the facts that  lead to the president's violation of the  zones of office and as a Catholic I  resent you're using work hate in a  sentence that addresses me I don't hate  anyone I was raised in a way that is  full a heart full of love and always  prayed for the president and I still  pray for the president I pray for the  president all the time so don't mess  with me when it comes to words like that  you